Les versets principaux qui nous concernent aujourd'hui, c'est les versets 7.
Dans nos traductions, il dit « Ne vous y trompez pas, on ne se moque pas des dieux ».
C'est la meilleure adaptation qu'on puisse faire avec notre langue pour traduire ce passage.
D'une manière plus littérale, les textes, il va plutôt dire « Dieu n'est pas passible des moqueries,
Dieu n'est pas moquable ».
Donc, ne vous trompez pas, ne tombez pas dans l'auto-déception.
Ne cherchez pas à raconter ces mensonges à vous-même dans vos vies quotidiennes.
C'est l'une des exhortations les plus importantes de la lettre des Galaxies,
c'est l'une des exhortations les plus importantes dans la Bible.
La crainte du Seigneur est le début de la sagesse.
Et l'athéisme est décrit dans la Bible comme dans la folie de l'auto-déception.
Les fous disent dans son cœur « Il n'y a pas Dieu ».
C'est lui-même qui essaie de se convaincre de cette réalité.
Et c'est une folie tout simplement car tout autour de lui donne des évidences
que nous vivons dans un monde qui est marqué par les empreintes des dieux,
par l'intelligence qu'on voit autour de nous,
par la bonté des choses qu'on puisse réduire.
Mais même à l'intérieur de l'être humain, malgré son éloignement des dieux,
il a une conscience qui porte encore les restes de ce qu'on peut appeler même les décalogues,
les dix commandements.
La moralité des dieux.
Si nous trouvons de la coupabilité en nous,
pour plus qu'on essaie de supprimer,
d'amortir,
nous savons que plus tôt ou plus tard, cette coupabilité reviendra.
Et donc,
l'expérience de tous les êtres humains
est vécue,
dans un certain sens,
devant cette possibilité.
Nous tromper constamment pour céder
à nos désirs charnels,
à nos passions égoïstes,
immédiates,
à cause de notre corruption,
et presque de manière instantive,
dans notre condition échouée,
même sachant que la réalité des dieux
est évidente,
nous voulons nous convaincre
que Dieu n'est pas là,
qu'il ne voit pas,
et on essaie de retarder
les jours où on va tous rendre compte
devant Dieu.
Donc, le fou dit dans son cœur,
il n'y a pas Dieu,
c'est une réalité générale,
universelle pour l'être humain.
Par contre,
certains
d'entre la race humaine
ont eu un vrai rencontre avec Dieu.
Et par la grâce de Dieu,
lorsque Dieu s'est révèle
à ceux qui sont sauvés,
Dieu va révéler son attirance,
Dieu va révéler sa sainteté,
ce qui va amplifier,
quelque part,
l'essence des condamnations,
l'essence des coupabilités,
sauf que lorsque Dieu
s'est fait présent
dans nos vies,
il ne nous prive pas
de la communication
de l'Évangile.
Et donc,
lorsque le Saint-Esprit
opère pour les saluts de quelqu'un,
il va lancer la lumière
vers la gloire de Dieu,
un Dieu qui devient désirable,
mais en même temps,
la lumière sera aussi
reflétée envers nous.
Et nous nous verrons
tels que nous sommes.
Et tous les vrais chrétiens
ont eu l'expérience
d'un dégoût
envers eux-mêmes.
Ils arrêtent de se victimiser,
ils arrêtent de chercher
à ne pas nommer péché
par péché,
ils arrêtent de chercher
à coupabiliser les circonstances,
la manière dont ils ont été élevés,
les habitudes précédentes
dans leur vie
et ils se responsabilisent
de leur péché.
Ils ne vont plus appeler péché
maladie,
ils vont appeler péché
péché,
chair,
rébellion contre Dieu,
impiété.
Et dans son désespoir,
l'être humain pense
qu'il n'y a plus
de solution pour lui.
Devant la beauté de Dieu
et devant notre misère.
Et Dieu nous présente
le Seigneur Jésus-Christ.
Voilà pourquoi
dans toute évangélisation,
bien sûr que nous devons
présenter la sainteté
des dieux,
le Créateur,
la misère de l'homme
et la compabilité
de l'homme,
mais il faut toujours
communiquer
l'espoir de l'évangile.
Car devant
la sainteté des dieux
et notre misère,
toute la race humaine
est dans une certaine mesure
exposée.
et voilà pourquoi
ce qui reste pour l'être humain,
c'est décevoir
pour rester dans les péchés.
Les problèmes,
c'est que parfois même
d'entre ceux qui
professent l'évangile,
ceux qui se considèrent
chrétiens
et ceux qui ont
véritablement traversé
une expérience
des conversions,
ils ont compris
qu'ils ont été
réconciliés avec Dieu,
car les fils de Dieu
lui-même
ont dû
devenir un être humain,
vivre la vie parfaite
qu'aucun d'entre nous
n'est capable de vivre
et souffrir à la croix
pleinement
pour tous
nos péchés,
tous les péchés
que chacun d'entre nous
a commis
d'entre ceux
qui s'est rensovés
par l'Écrit.
Il était vraiment
mon représentant.
Il a vécu la vie parfaite
que je n'allais pas vivre.
Il est mort à la croix
pour moi.
Et donc,
tout être humain
véritablement converti
a été
dès les points
des départs
de sa foi
humilié.
Et s'il est
véritablement
dans la foi,
l'une des marques
principales
qui sera
trouvée dans sa vie,
c'est
ce qu'on appelle
la crainte
des dieux.
C'est la conscience
de sa misère.
Par contre,
pour des raisons
qui peuvent nous échapper,
variables,
notamment liées
au reste du péché
dans nos vies,
certains d'entre nous
vont plutôt développer
une vie
après la conversion
comme si Dieu
n'existait pas.
C'est une vie
des moqueries
envers Dieu.
Et quelque part,
cette vie devient
encore plus coupable,
encore plus
immorale
que la vie
de celui
qui n'a jamais
été converti.
car leur moquerie
n'a pas
une compréhension
expérimentale
de ce qui
Christ a
soffert pour nous,
de l'amour
de Dieu pour nous.
N'a pas
une relation
expérimentale
avec la présence
du Saint-Esprit
dans nos vies
qui nous donne
la capacité
de progresser
en santé,
de plaire Dieu.
Et donc,
malgré
la révélation
de l'Évangile
et une relation
avec Dieu,
certains d'entre nous
sont négligents
envers Dieu.
Et ce texte,
il parle particulièrement
de cette situation.
Lorsqu'il dit
ne vous y trompez pas,
on ne se moque pas
des dieux,
c'est une vérité universelle
qui veut pour tout le monde,
mais dans le contexte
de cette lettre,
c'est pour corriger
un grand problème
chez les Galates,
au-dedans
d'une église.
À chaque fois
qu'il nous méprisons
chaque opportunité
que Dieu nous donne
pour progresser
en santé,
c'est une moquerie
envers Dieu.
Et donc,
cette exhortation
fait partie
de la conclusion
de toute la lettre
des Galates
et cette exhortation,
elle est énormément pratique.
La Bible,
elle est les livres
les plus pratiques
de l'existence humaine.
ce qu'on nomme
a racémé,
il moissonnera aussi.
Ce qui est évident
et transparent
dans nos vies aujourd'hui,
la manière dont les personnes
voient notre style de vie,
notre comportement,
elles sont en train
de contempler
ce que nous avons
constamment
dans notre quotidien,
dans notre routine,
dans les mois précédents,
dans les années précédentes,
dans la vie
de tous les jours,
c'est ce que nous sommes
en train de cultiver.
Nous sommes
à l'extérieur,
car c'est Dieu
qui voit vraiment
à l'intérieur,
comme on a,
les fruits
qu'on porte,
l'aspect visible,
c'est quelque part
la réalité
du résultat
de ce que nous avons
cultivé.
et donc,
c'est très important
pour nous
de nous responsabiliser,
surtout les chrétiens,
par rapport
à la manière
dont on vit.
Et cette exhortation,
elle est importante,
car
l'Église des Galates
était en train
de se moquer
des dieux
dans la pratique
à plusieurs égards,
mais Paul est ici
en train de faire appel
à quelque chose
qui ne peut
qu'émarcher,
attention,
et ne peut
n'est pas marcher,
vous êtes avec moi,
je vais répéter,
ne peut qu'émarcher
et ne peut
n'est pas marcher
dans la vie
du chrétien.
Paul,
il aurait pu
lutter
avec les cynismes
des êtres humains
dans cette Église.
on a tous
cette capacité,
je pense qu'on doit
tous se laisser
réprocher parfois
dans la capacité
que nous avons
de faire usage
de notre intelligence
pour rationaliser
nos péchés,
pour nous excuser,
car depuis la chute,
c'est comme ça
qu'Adam a fait,
coupabiliser les autres,
les circonstances,
les permissions
des dieux.
Et dans les travails
pastoraux,
des fois,
c'est très fatigant
en essayant
de réconcilier
les choses
ou en essayant
de rendre
une personne
plus diligente
dans sa vie,
dans sa sanctification,
en essayant
de régler
certains problèmes
dans les vies
de certains,
lorsque nous voyons
de manière très claire
que cette personne
est une personne
qui est en train
de se moquer
de Dieu,
qui est en train
de mépriser
les capacités
qu'elle a reçues
des dieux,
les bénédictions
que Dieu a déjà
pourvues,
et on perd
beaucoup de temps
et d'énergie
car,
nous essayons
tout simplement
de faire un dialogue
entre êtres
et humains.
Mais à un moment donné,
soit la réalité
de la présence
du Saint-Esprit
des dieux
est là,
soit la crainte
des dieux
est là,
soit cette personne
a eu véritablement
une expérience
des conversions
qui l'a unie
avec Christ
et elle connaît
en fait
quelle est la loi
qui doit régir
nos vies,
cette loi
dont notre serveur
a porté
tous nos fardeaux
sur lui
et il nous laisse
cette vie
de porter la croix
chaque jour,
d'arrêter
de pleurer,
de nous plaindre
et de dire
oui,
c'est une croix
qui m'est réservée,
je la prends
et je fais
ce qui plaît
Dieu.
c'est la guerre
constante
et donc Paul
il fait appel
à l'authenticité
de l'expérience
des conversions
de chaque individu
dans cette communauté
et c'est la meilleure
manière de régler
ces problèmes.
Il est en train
d'utiliser
trois expressions
qui sont capitales
dans la vie chrétienne.
La première
c'est
marcher dans l'esprit
ce qui n'est qu'est possible
pour les croyants.
celui qui est converti
c'est celui qui est devenu
habitation
du Saint-Esprit
de Dieu.
La troisième personne
de la Sainte Trinité
Dieu lui-même
tout puissant
est là
pour nous sanctifier.
Son influence
est infiniment
plus élevée
que l'influence
des restes
et de la chair
chez un chrétien.
Et donc
c'est clair
qu'il ne manque
aucune ressource
de la part de Dieu
pour que si nous marchons
dans l'esprit
on est satisfait
point
les désirs
de la chair.
La deuxième couche
à laquelle Paul
fait appel
qui est à l'intérieur
des chats chrétiens
c'est
d'avoir professé
notre union
par la foi
Christ
portez vos fardeaux
les uns des autres
et vous accomplirez
ainsi
la loi
du Christ.
Si je me déclare
chrétien
je dois me rappeler
je suis mort
avec Christ
pour les péchés
et ressuscité
avec Christ
pour une nouvelle vie.
Je suis
une branche
qui était morte
et qui était
greffée
dans la vie vivante
et vivifiante
qu'est Christ.
Donc je vais suivre
les paramètres du Christ
et je vais être diligent
pour me sanctifier.
Et donc
quelqu'un qui est
insensible
vers l'œuvre du Christ
pour sa vie
il est en train
de se moquer
des dieux.
et la troisième couche
c'est celle
qui est la plus importante
pour nous aujourd'hui
c'est cette camp
des dieux.
Ne vous y trompez pas
la patience
des dieux
que Dieu est en train
d'exercer envers vous
pour qu'il vous avancez
dans la vie
dans les biens
pour qu'il vous persévérez
malgré tout
cette patience
n'est pas
complicité
à cette vie
que vous êtes en train
de mener.
Vous êtes en train
de mépriser
tant d'opportunités
pour faire les biens
pour cultiver les biens
pour organiser
votre agenda
en priorisant les biens
pour rejeter les péchés
pour résister aux péchés
mais
Dieu sait
et vous le savez aussi
quelles puissances
sont à votre disposition.
Dieu le sait
et vous le savez aussi
quelles bonnes influences
Dieu vous a entouré.
Dieu le sait
et vous le savez aussi
qu'il a
un zèle
particulier
pour les choses sacrées
pour l'Église.
N'agissez pas
dans un lieu
sacré
comme un imposteur.
et donc
ne vous trompez pas
Dieu n'est pas
moquable.
Donc cette exhortation
elle vaut
bien sûr
pour la conversion
de nos chrétiens
mais elle est
particulièrement dirigée
aux chrétiens
et c'est notamment
cette notion
de se moquer
de Dieu
à laquelle
on devrait être
intéressé
donc les versets
jusqu'au verset 6
ce sont des exemples
variables
ce ne sont pas
tous les exemples
mais ce sont des exemples
variables
de comment
dans notre vie
au sein d'une Église
ou dans notre vie
pratique
on a une tendance
à nous moquer
de Dieu.
Donc par exemple
verset 26
ne cherchons pas
une vaine gloire
en nous provoquant
les uns les autres
en nous portant
en vie les uns les autres
donc les divisions
au sein de l'Église
qui sont issues
de l'intérêt
de certains
donc on se rappelle
du contexte des Galates
je ne vais pas revenir
à tout mais
certains qui voulaient
exposer leur connaissance
théologique
et vouloient sembler
être correct
mais il ne suffit pas
même d'être correct
en ayant
une attitude divisive
et donc
ce sont ceux
qui sont
emparés
d'une vaine gloire
qui professent
avec leur foi
ou leur profession
des fois dire
que les moments
de leur conversion
ils n'étaient rien
ils méritaient l'enfer
ils ont la capacité
d'avoir un langage
et un discours
d'humilité
mais
leur procédure
au sein de l'Église
est une procédure
marquée
par la sensation
ou l'impression
qu'ils se sentent
plus importants
que d'autres
plus sains
que les autres
sauf qu'ils ne sont pas
en train de prendre
en considération
l'ensemble
de l'histoire
de chacun
il regarde
l'apparence
extérieure
de sa vie
et parfois
il y a quelqu'un
qui est en train
de vivre
une bataille
contre un péché
qui est un peu
plus visible
mais qui est
sincère
et son point
de départ
était
beaucoup plus
tragique
que celui
du légaliste
qui est rempli
de vain-gloire
et donc
dans cette vain-gloire
il cherche
à provoquer
à s'aimer
des divisions
car
il a envie
donc là
c'est une manière
de se moquer
de Dieu
car
l'Évangile
entre autres choses
enseigne avant tout
et il crée avant tout
des êtres
profondément humiliés
et humbles
ensuite
la manière
dont on essaie
de redresser
quelqu'un
qui a été surpris
dans une faute
quelqu'un
a été surpris
dans une faute
et cette personne
remplie de vain-gloire
elle est tout de suite
tentée
à manifester
sa supériorité
par la manière
dont elle essaie
de corriger
un autre
elle est lourde
dans la manière
et pourquoi
c'est une moquerie
car les jours
où Christ
a dû venir
pardonner
ses fautes
et son péché
Christ
a été
celui qui a enlevé
les fardeaux
de la culpabilité
qui était lourd
qu'il a porté
il nous a donné
un fardeau léger
il est en train
d'oublier
qu'il a cette solidarité
dans les péchés
donc voilà pourquoi
les textes disent
redressez-le
avec douceur
et prends garde
à toi-même
des peurs
que tu ne sois
aussi tenté
donc lorsque
nous sommes vite
à juger les autres
nous sommes en train
de nous moquer
des dieux
au sein de la communauté
si quelqu'un
pense être quelque chose
verset 3
en pardon verset 2
ensuite
portez les fardeaux
les uns des autres
et vous accomplirez
ainsi la loi du Christ
donc au lieu
de rajouter des fardeaux
dans la vie
de celui qui a péché
qui a péché
on doit plutôt
chercher
à porter son fardeau
lui pointer
envers Christ
pour qu'il puisse
régler sa coupabilité
avec Christ
avec Dieu
réconcilier
et l'aider
à surmonter
les péchés
dans lesquels
il est tombé
sans rendre
trop visible
la situation
donc
la loi du Christ
c'est qu'on porte
nos fardeaux
mutuellement
qu'on soit
plus concentré
à aider
les autres
qu'il réclame
notre droit
que les autres
portent notre fardeau
promouvoir la vie
les uns des autres
et ensuite
notre manière
de se moquer
de Dieu
c'est la manière
dont
on ne cherche pas
à porter
notre propre fardeau
qu'est-ce que cela veut dire ?
ça veut dire que
Dieu a réservé
un lot
pour chacun d'entre nous
les fardeaux
peut-être
la bataille
contre un péché
les fardeaux
peut-être
les difficultés
dans la vie
les injustices
qu'on souffre
et la réalité
c'est qu'aucune
de ces circonstances
ne peut servir
d'excuse
par rapport
à ce que Dieu
pourvoit pour nous
et les modèles
des vies
qui Christ
nous a laissés
si je suis préoccupé
à examiner
mes propres oeuvres
je n'essaierai pas
en train de m'abuser
à moi-même
je ne suis pas là
en train de comparer
ma vie
avec la vie des autres
car Dieu est le seul
qui peut voir
l'ensemble
de la vie de chacun
et des fois
quelqu'un
qui est tombé
dans un péché
et qui a répenti
son serment
dans l'ensemble
du jugement divan
il peut être
dans une position
encore plus élevée
que c'est lui
qui n'a pas
tombé dans un péché
mais qui est rempli
d'arrogance
et donc
devant les lots
qui Dieu m'a réservé
pour aujourd'hui
je dois
porter mon fardeau
et savoir
que chacun
portera son propre fardeau
c'est-à-dire
chacun va rendre compte
devant Dieu
dans les jours
du jugement final
cette emphase
nous enseigne
que
c'est de me moquer
de Dieu
de ne pas faire
ce que je dois faire
tout simplement
d'assumer
ma responsabilité
d'agir comme Christ
aujourd'hui
donc
au verset 6
la dernière manière
dont on peut être
en train de se moquer
de Dieu
c'est celui
à qui
l'on enseigne la parole
fasse part
de tous ses biens
à celui
qui l'enseigne
donc cette générosité
envers
un des moyens
à travers lesquels
Dieu peut
douer
ou doter
l'église
faire cadeau
à l'église
pour que
cette église
reçoive
l'influence
et la motivation
pour être davantage
cultivée
dans les biens
si Dieu veut
produire
les fruits
de l'esprit
entre nous
si Dieu veut
opérer
les saluts
l'un des dons
les plus importants
qu'il peut donner
à une église
c'est un homme
des dieux
selon les critères
bibliques
un homme
des dieux
authentique
c'est lui qui a
pour fonction principale
enseigné la parole
et donc
nous devons
cultiver
et investir
quelque part
dans cette
générosité
sachant que
c'est une manière
d'investir
dans notre vie
spirituelle
et lorsque
nous sommes en train
de nous moquer
de l'homme des dieux
dans les contextes
surtout
de la lettre
des pôles aux galates
ce sont
les vrais pasteurs
qui étaient là
car cette église
a été envahie
par des judaïsants
des faux pasteurs
et cette église
était en train
plutôt d'honorer
ces faux pasteurs
qui étaient les pasteurs
authentiques
qui avaient été placés
de la part des dieux
et donc
c'est une moquerie
envers dieux
ok
ce sont les manières
dont nous pouvons
nous moquer des dieux
mais la question
la plus importante
pour nous
c'est pas
si tant
de considérer
de quelle manière
nous pouvons être
en train
de nous moquer des dieux
mais de considérer
cette motivation capitale
du pourquoi
c'est une folie
de nous moquer des dieux
donc au verset 7
ne vous y trompez pas
on ne s'est moquant pas
des dieux
la vérité centrale
pour nous
il y a deux
vérités
évidemment
ici
dans les passages
donc dans les versets 7
là où on va placer
la vérité centrale
ne vous y trompez pas
on ne s'est moquant pas
des dieux
c'est qu'on a mort
à s'aimer
il les moissonnera aussi
et plus tard
au verset 9
on voit
l'implication pratique
la plus explicite
du passage
et l'implication
c'est qu'on ne peut pas
relâcher
de pratiquer les biens
donc la vérité centrale
est celle-ci
il est impossible
de se moquer
des dieux
donc les chrétiens
doivent persévérer
dans la culture du bien
car Dieu n'est pas moquable
car Dieu n'est pas passé
des moqueries
les chrétiens
doivent vivre
une vie constante
pour s'aimer les biens
ok
on a déjà considéré
deux vérités
qui nous aident
à comprendre mieux
cette vérité centrale
donc la question pour nous
c'est
quel principe
ces textes
met en avant
pour nous garder
dans une détermination
constante
à cultiver
et à pratiquer
les biens
la première réponse
c'est celle
qui est là
évidemment
dans les versets 7
qui nous dit
que Dieu
n'est pas passible
des moqueries
nous devons persévérer
et déterminer
à cultiver les biens
car Dieu n'est pas passible
des moqueries
et nous avons considéré
cette folie
de chercher
à nous tromper
par deux perspectives
c'est une folie
d'essayer
de se moquer
de Dieu
déjà car
l'homme
est très petit
et vulnérable
donc on est
humilié
temporellement
même par un arbre
qui va vivre
plus que nous
on est davantage
humilié
par notre récidive
dans nos péchés
et voilà pourquoi
c'est de la folie
selon la Bible
de se dire
dans notre cœur
il n'y a pas Dieu
les non-croyants
les disent
car ils sont esclaves
de leur passion charnelle
les chrétiens
ne disent pas
que Dieu n'existait pas
mais dans leur vie pratique
s'ils négligent
la cultivation du bien
ils sont en train
de commettre
ce qu'on appelle
un athéisme pragmatique
vivre comme si Dieu
n'existait pas
nous nous moquons
des dieux
donc dans la manière
dont on organise
nos vies
et dans la pratique
comme on a vu
mais par la perspective
de la grandeur
des dieux
c'est davantage
effrayant
et c'est davantage
folle
de se moquer
des dieux
donc
la Bible
elle présente
on ne se moque
pas des dieux
c'est qu'un homme
aura s'aimé
et il moçonnera aussi
donc
Dieu n'est pas
passible
des moqueries
car bien sûr
dans l'être des dieux
dans ses attributs
c'est un dieux
qui a toute la puissance
qui ne peut être
jamais frustré
et qui a
un accès
direct
constant
exhaustif
et profond
à propos
de tous nos pensées
de tous nos sentiments
de toutes nos actions
Dieu le sait
par exemple
qui est lorsque
les prédicateurs
entrent des prêchers
ici
vous êtes tous
exposés aux exhortations
des dieux
lui-même
envers vous
mais il connaît aussi
les intentions
des certains
d'entre vous
qui peuvent peut-être
se dire dans votre coeur
c'est ma pilule
hebdomadaire
d'une anesthésie
pour ma coupabilité
je sais qu'à la fond
au fond de moi-même
je ne suis pas vraiment
intéressé
à laisser certains péchés
à devenir
diligent
dans ma relation
avec Dieu
je suis là
pour alléger
un peu ma conscience
et ça
c'est une moquerie
envers Dieu
qui personne ne peut échapper
car Dieu
les dieux créateurs
il a accès
à chaque instant
direct
il est un dieux
omniscient
il sait tout
mais les textes
ils parlent des lois
des lois naturelles
il est les dieux créateurs
il est les dieux
de la providence
c'est impossible
de sémer
la séance
d'une pomme
et voir un poirier
pousser de la terre
les lois
qui Dieu a établies
à nouveau
les scientifiques
ils s'éventent
de vouloir
découvrir ces lois
ou connu
cette loi
organiser ces lois
mais qui a créé
cette loi
c'est Dieu
et les textes
il est en train
de nous enseigner
que les lois
que Dieu a établies
sont tellement fermes
fixées et certaines
que nous pouvons
être si sûr
comme nous sommes sûrs
que le soleil
sera levé
dément
à la même heure
que toutes les choses
qu'on s'aime
on va raconter
et nous devons
nos responsabilités
car notre vie
aujourd'hui
nos difficultés
à nouveau
parfois on est en train
de vouloir
exiger de la part
de Dieu
qu'il soit mieux
envers nous
on est en train
de se plaindre
des difficultés
qu'on traverse
aujourd'hui
on attend
un miracle
mais la réalité
c'est que nous
sommes encore
en train de s'aimer
les choses
qu'on a racontées
et si certaines choses
ne changent pas
nous ne pouvons pas
attendre
que les résultats
soient différents
les lois spirituelles
elles ont été faites
par les mêmes
Dieu
qui a créé
les lois
naturelles
c'est ça
les raisonnements
du texte
les dieux créateurs
mais Dieu
il est non seulement
en train de dire
ça va se passer
comme ça
car les lois
ont été établies
donc on va dire
une espèce
des lois
impersonnelles
un rapport
automatique
envers la vie
au Dieu
non
ce que Dieu
est en train
de dire
c'est que
Paul est en train
de laisser clair
c'est que
Dieu
n'est pas
moquable
car il a
un intérêt
particulier
et un zèle
il n'est pas
tout simplement
à la place
du créateur
qui a établi
des lois
naturelles
et spirituelles
il est à la place
du juge
très saint
qu'il est
et donc
c'est impossible
de supprimer
de la religion
de la vraie religion
la religion chrétienne
l'élément
constant
des relations
personnelles
avec Dieu
nous ne sommes pas
qu'ils dévend
les lois
d'une culture
comme si on était
dans un champ
un automatisme
il y a
de la
personification
ou la personnalité
des dieux
de la relation
personnelle
à chaque instant
et Dieu
dans sa position
des juges
il participe
à nos vies
certaines conséquences
peuvent venir
de manière presque
automatique
on a pris l'habitude
pendant une période
de nos vies
de nous droguer
par exemple
de prendre
beaucoup de médicaments
à un moment donné
même après la conversion
on est pardonné
nos péchés
on peut même
arriver à délaisser
ces choses
mais parfois
les conséquences
les cicatrices
de nos décisions
passées
restent
et la réalité
c'est que
ces choses
peuvent avoir
ces conséquences
de manière
automatique
mais la réalité
c'est que
Dieu
en tant que
juge
de l'univers
il est constamment
actif
dans cette affaire
ce n'est pas
une menace
à laquelle
on serait
susceptible
aux probabilités
ou aux possibilités
selon les lois
de la création
c'est une assurance
que Dieu
est en train
d'établir
et d'exhorter
ce qu'un homme
aura s'aimé
il va
moissonner
aussi
et donc
Dieu
n'est pas
passible
des moqueries
car il ne laissera
aucun péché
en puni
et donc
bien sûr
que nous cherchons
à équilibrer
ça
avec notre
compréhension
de l'évangile
car la
réalité
du pardon
que Dieu nous donne
et de la générosité
que Dieu peut utiliser
dans nos vies
parfois
pour qu'on puisse
raccolter
de la grâce
lorsqu'on a sémé
de la corruption
ça ne va pas
annuler
les faits
que quelqu'un
a dû
raconter
ce qu'on a
sémé
écoutez bien
et voilà pourquoi
la moquerie
envers Dieu
devient encore plus
immorale
et grave
si nous ne sommes pas
chrétiens
et qu'on a fait
qu'il
raconte
les mâles
et qu'à partir
d'un moment
où on est converti
et qu'on a reçu
une très belle
opportunité
pour une nouvelle vie
nous sommes en train
de raconter
de la grâce
et même
des bénédictions
temporelles
pour lesquelles
nous on n'a pas
s'émé
mais quelqu'un
d'autre
a dû s'aimer
cette loi
ne peut pas
faillir
lorsqu'il
Christ était
à la croix
il a été
la croix
après avoir
accompli
parfaitement
toute la loi
à notre place
et la manière
dont Dieu
est en train
de traiter
avec nous
les chrétiens
aujourd'hui
par grâce
c'est car
Jésus
a dû être
traité
par justice
cette punition
absolue
et Dieu
pour nous
peut anticiper
quelques grâces
qu'on va raconter
pour toute l'éternité
de manière parfaite
et Dieu
peut être en train
d'exercer
une patience
envers les non-chrétiens
afin
qu'ils aient
l'opportunité
de connaître
l'évangile
mais il y aura
un jour
le jugement final
où tout sera
réglé
mais la réalité
c'est que
si nous sommes
véritablement chrétiens
et que nous voulons
réjouir
de cette grâce
sur grâce
de la part
de Dieu
c'est évident
et explicite
dans la Bible
que nous ne pouvons
pas jouer
avec les hauts prix
du salut gratuit
qu'on a reçu
car il n'y a pas
un grand intérêt
de la part
de Dieu
de préserver
en vie
des personnes
qui sont
véritablement sauvées
mais qui vont jouer
plus pour la diffamation
de l'évangile
contre
l'avancement
de l'évangile
et voilà pourquoi
on a médité aussi
à la sainte scène
dans cette question
des certains
qui sont morts
d'autres qui dorent
et l'assurance
de Breux
qui nous parle
de la correction
des dieux
tous les enfants
sont disciplinés
et donc
pour nous les chrétiens
on doit attendre
que la main des dieux
pèse sur nous
si nous sommes
en train
de nous moquer
des dieux
constamment
on a vu aussi
ces deuxièmes points
qui nous enseignent
que nous devons
persévérer
déterminer
à cultiver
les biens
car les résultats
de ce qui nous sème
sont irrésistibles
celui qui sème
pour sa chair
moissonnera
de la chair
la corruption
mais celui qui sème
pour l'esprit
moissonnera
de l'esprit
la vie éternelle
donc on a bien
considéré
l'inévitabilité
soit des récompenses
même si
on peut avoir
l'impression
qu'elles tardent
et l'inévitabilité
des punitions
des conséquences
si on est en train
de s'aimer
pour la chair
si on est en train
de négliger
une vie
qui est organisée
constamment
pour cultiver
la vie de l'esprit
c'est impossible
de ne pas
réveiller un cadre
vicieux
de s'aimer
et cultiver
la corruption
donc bien sûr
que
cette corruption
ne parle pas
d'une corruption
même éternelle
et là
l'exhortation
pour tous les chrétiens
c'est
à la fin des comptes
si jamais
entre nous
nous avons
des imposteurs
plus tôt
plus tard
l'arbre
sera reconnu
par ses fruits
et donc
les exhortations
bibliques
par rapport
à l'apostasie
elles ne nous parlent
pas de la possibilité
qu'un vrai chrétien
perde son salut
elles nous parlent
de la manière
dont Dieu
à long terme
va démontrer
que quelqu'un
qui vivait
une vie
scandaleuse
en cachette
à un moment donné
dévoile
sa vraie nature
mais de l'autre côté
ces exhortations
elles ne peuvent
qu'éjouer
dans les vies
de vrais chrétiens
car la crainte
du Seigneur
elle n'habite
qu'éché
les vrais chrétiens
et lorsqu'un vrai
chrétien
est exhorté
ne vous moquez
pas des dieux
il est le premier
à redresser
sa vie
à se corriger
vous êtes avec moi ?
et donc voilà
pourquoi cette exhortation
elle est très importante
ce sont des avertissements
surtout pour les croyants
mais aussi pour les imposteurs
car les croyants
ce sont ceux
qui souffriront
la discipline
corrective
du Père Céleste
pour que nos vies
soient davantage
fructifères
vous vous rappelez
de cette parabole
où le Seigneur
de la vigne
va dire
ça fait déjà
trois ans
j'attends
que ça porte du fruit
c'est figué
et ça porte pas
et l'avreur
c'est comme ça
que vous dites
celui qui travaille
sur les champs
les laboureurs
il va dire
donne moi encore
quelques mois
je vais couper
quelques branches
je vais un peu
faire de la violence
pour nettoyer
les terrains
et on verra
si ça changera
et parfois
c'est ça
qui va faire
les changements
dans nos vies
si c'est nécessaire
Seigneur
que je traverse
de la difficulté
qu'il soit en si
et donc là
cette exhortation
est importante
et les motivations
sont certaines
donc si je sème
les biens
je vais raconter
donc je vais
véritablement
organiser ma vie
de manière
à sème les biens
le troisième point
qui est important
pour nous
c'est celui-ci
nous devons
persévérer
déterminer
à cultiver les biens
car l'étang
des dieux
est parfait
donc lisons ensemble
les versets 9
ne nous laissons pas
de faire les biens
car nous moissonnerons
autant qu'on vénable
si nous ne relâchons pas
dans l'original
plutôt
les biens
est d'abord
mentionné
dans les passages
les biens
ne nous laissons pas
de faire
donc ces biens
bien sûr
selon le contexte
on peut parler
d'un bien
qui nous concerne
donc attention
ne vous moquez
pas des dieux
ok
cherchons
à accueillir
les biens
un bien
que nous ne pourrions
jamais produire
de nous-mêmes
par contre
les biens
ont été mis
à votre disposition
ce qui veut dire
pour un non-chrétien
qu'il est devant
l'étang
de l'opportunité
quelqu'un
qui n'a jamais
pris au sérieux
sa relation
avec Dieu
même quelqu'un
qui a vécu
une vie
hypocrite
avec Dieu
ou par exemple
nos enfants
qui ont été
élevés
dans un cadre
chrétien
religieux
mais qui n'ont
pas encore
traversé
la conversion
ça serait
une moquerie
de leur part
de vivre
une vie
à l'opposé
des exemples
et de la mesure
des grâces
à laquelle
ils étaient exposés
et donc
ils doivent
abandonner
souplier
Dieu
pour que ça
devienne
une réalité
dans leur vie
et donc
les biens
nous n'allons pas
négliger
l'opportunité
qui est devant nous
ok
mais à nouveau
les textes
ils sont surtout
dirigés
aux chrétiens
et cela veut dire
notamment
saisir
chaque opportunité
pour faire
les biens
ces biens
spirituels
envers nous
cultiver les biens
les fruits de l'esprit
nous sanctifier
et les biens
envers les autres
et là on peut
révenir au passage
intérieur
qui nous parle
comment on doit
réadresser les personnes
comment on doit être
humble
etc
donc les biens
nous ne pouvons pas
laisser les faire
donc dans l'original
c'est de ne pas
perdre
les courage
c'est de ne pas
perdre
le coeur
c'est de ne pas
se laisser
fatiguer
de faire les biens
et là c'est un grand
défi pour les chrétiens
pour les chrétiens
authentiques
sincères
pour les chrétiens
qui ont véritablement
expérimenté
l'oeuvre de la grâce
dans leur vie
pourquoi
car ces mondes
sous la chute
nous donnent
énormément
de motivation
pour être fatigué
de faire les biens
on fait les biens
et on reçoit
en retour
l'ingratitude
on fait les biens
l'église fait les biens
et elle est persécutée
la vie pour un chrétien
dans une société
corrompue
est beaucoup plus difficile
que la vie pour un non-chrétien
un chrétien par exemple
cherche à être à jour
avec tous ses impôts
par contre
l'entreprise
qui dispute
les marchés
avec les chrétiens
parfois
n'est pas en train
d'être honnête
à cet égard
les chrétiens
qui travaillent
dans les commerces
il doit être
véritable
dans la manière
dont il va chercher
à faire une vente
les non-chrétiens
fiendront
différemment
partout dans la vie
un vrai chrétien
qui a la grandeté
de Dieu
est défié
faire les biens
on est fatigué
avec les mépris
parfois
car on ne voit pas
les résultats
dans les timings
qu'on aimerait
parfois
nous sommes diffamés
nous souffrons
l'injustice
parfois
on est fatigué
car on voit
les manques
des proportions
vis-à-vis
aux investissements
reçus
on considère
les heures
et les heures
qui ont été investies
dans la vie de chacun
avec des bons enseignements
avec de l'amour
avec de la patience
la prédisposition
est pardonnée
et à chaque fois
une opportunité
nouvelle
est saisie
pour plutôt
faire les mal
qu'elle est bien
on voit
que certains
sont là
en train de porter
des loups fardeaux
pour les biens
des autres
pendant que
certains autres
sont tout simplement
en train de profiter
du loups fardeau
porté par un petit
nombre
on peut être fatigué
par les besoins
constants
de répéter
les mêmes choses
mais nous pouvons
aussi être fatigué
par des barrières
parfois institutionnelles
qui nous empêchent
d'être plus rapides
et plus vite
la résistance par exemple
des mairies
pour nous permettre
d'utiliser un espace
pour être l'église
ou même dans l'institution
de l'église
par manque
de ressources
zoomant
nous sommes parfois
devant un grand champ
qu'on voulait
continuer d'avancer
et nous n'avons pas
de ressources
pour les faire
et surtout
les ressources zoomant
les personnes
qui malgré
les investissements
qui sont là
et parfois même
les ressources financières
sont un peu
ralenties
dans leur prédisposition
à s'engager
à s'impliquer
totalement
dans les champs
dans les ministères
nous pouvons être
fatigués
par les récidives
malgré notre discipline
à progresser
la bataille
contre un péché
et c'est dur
parfois
car on a beau
essayer
plusieurs méthodes
plusieurs manières
mais on est surpris
parfois
avec les mêmes comportements
on accède
des colères
on manque
des maîtrises
de soi
par rapport
à ce qu'on mange
les recours
qu'on fait
quand on va
chercher
la pharmacie
à régler
les problèmes
qui sont d'abord
spirituels
avec des ressources
qu'on sait
qui sont de ce monde
et qui n'ont pas
la capacité
de régler le problème
qui ne font que
suspendre
les ressentir
du problème
les psychotropes
et là
on est
découragé
c'est très important
de juger
dans ces moments
que malgré
le fait
qu'on a été
récidif
si nous sommes
véritablement
déterminés
à être disciplinés
à être
diligents
si on n'est pas
en train
de moquer
des dieux
c'est vrai
que même là
parfois
nous sommes surpris
par les restes
de la chair
et c'est fatiguant
mais nous sommes
déjà
et nous devrons
l'être
si nous sommes
chrétiens
beaucoup mieux
que ce qu'on était
un jour
chaque petite étape
qu'on a accomplie
chaque petit pas
on doit
affirmer
bien les pas
et ne pas permettre
de revenir en arrière
et si un récidive
a eu lieu
on n'a pas
besoin de recommencer
le départ
on se relève
dès là où nous sommes
et on avance
mais le plus dur
c'est les récidives
par négligence
qui n'ont pas été
accompagnées
d'un changement
radical
dans la bataille
contre ses péchés
c'est un récidive
qui est clairement
évidemment
une moquerie
envers Dieu
et aux investissements
qui ont été faits
c'est la moquerie
envers Dieu
et c'est encore plus
décevant parfois
et décourageant
quand on contemple
les imposteurs
dévoilés
quand on contemple
au sein de la communauté
quelque chose
qui parfois
nous échappe
c'est qu'il y a
une crise
quel est l'intérêt
de certains
de s'émêler
dans une assemblée
religieuse chrétienne
si leur intérêt
n'est pas
véritablement
d'avoir une relation
avec Dieu
et des fois
même les pasteurs
peuvent être
énormément découragés
car des fois
ils se demandent
mais quel est
l'essence
de tout ça
parfois
on a la sensation
que pour certains
on est qui en train
dédonner de l'anesthésie
aux endulgens
cyniques
qui ne veulent pas
progresser
et des fois
on a l'impression
qu'on est plutôt
en train d'équiper
des prédateurs
imposteurs
au sein de la communauté
car ils peuvent apprendre
les langages bibliques
les bonnes manières
et Dieu
qui est intéressé
qui nous déchirions
plutôt nos cœurs
que nos vêtements
une des choses
qui
personnellement
mettons-les plus
dans la vie
d'un grand repère
pour moi
en nombre de Dieu
assez connu
c'est que malgré
les faits
qu'autour de lui
plusieurs personnes
surtout dans
les dernières années
ont tombé
dans des péchés graves
ont été disqualifiées
pour les mystères
des personnes
qui étaient même
des repères pour lui
et surtout des personnes
dans son cercle
plus proche
des imposteurs
qui ont commis
des graves péchés
même l'abus
!
sexuels envers un enfant
un membre
de son cercle
de son équipe
missionnaire
le plus étonnant
pour moi
c'est la manière
dont il persévère
à donner
de l'opportunité
aux autres personnes
je vous ai partagé
énormément
d'émotifs
de découragement
par contre
si on était livré
à nous-mêmes
les septicimes
seraient inévitables
heureusement
nous ne sommes pas
livrés nous-mêmes
nous sommes mêlés
par la grâce
de Dieu
en affaires
qui nous dépassent
ce sont des choses
qui concernent
avant tout
et surtout
à Dieu
un Dieu
qui est en zèle
énorme
pour son peuple
et pour son église
et la réalité
c'est que Dieu
ne permet pas
que ces choses
durent longtemps
soit il va discipliner
plus tôt ou plus tard
les vrais chrétiens
soit les imposteurs
seront chassés
du sang
des églises véritables
ou s'y convertir
par la grâce
de Dieu
véritablement
nous ne pouvons pas
douter
que nous devons
persévérer
à faire les biens
même quand nous sommes
tentés
à être découragés
car l'étang
de Dieu
est parfait
remarquez bien
ne nous laissons pas
de faire les biens
car nous moissonnerons
au temps
convenable
au temps convenable
dans l'original
chronos
ou kairos
c'est le mot
kairos
les temps
convenables
des dieux
il y a ces deux
usages
de temps
dans la Bible
les chronos
c'est tout simplement
la séquence du temps
la manière dont on est
en train de marquer
les jours
mais les kairos
c'est les temps
parfait des dieux
un dieu qui ne peut pas
être frustré
dans son planning
un dieu qui sait
exactement les moments
exacts
où il doit intervenir
les kairos
parlent
de l'intervention
des dieux
il n'y a rien
qui soit inactif
pendant les périodes
d'attente
il n'y a rien
qui soit inactif
même lorsqu'on est en train
de s'aimer
et de cultiver
et qu'on n'est pas
en train de voir
la maçon
qu'on aimerait
recevoir
autant convenable
c'est sûr et certain
que nous allons
moissonner
les biens
qu'on est en train
de cultiver
et qu'on doit
continuer de cultiver
et même
pendant les temps
que nous sommes
en train de s'aimer
et cultiver
et qu'on n'est pas
encore en train
de voir les résultats
que ce soit chez nous
ou à travers nous
envers les autres
c'est très important
de nous rappeler
que Dieu a
des buts multiples
tous les longs
du schéma
c'est plus important
de considérer
ce que Dieu est en train
de faire en nous
pendant les temps
d'attente
qu'on est en train
de cultiver
qu'est-ce que Dieu
peut faire à nous
les bénédictions
qu'on aimerait recevoir
ou de ce que Dieu
pourrait faire
à travers de nous
même les services
pour la gloire de Dieu
car l'intérêt primaire
de Dieu
c'est sa relation
d'amour avec nous
et pendant la souffrance
et pendant l'attente
il est en train
de nous travailler
de nous préparer
l'attente
et la préparation
et donc c'est très intéressant
de remarquer
dans la Bible
les plans de la rédemption
on voit
qu'on a dû
attendre 3-4 000 ans
jusqu'à ce que
Christ arrive
est-ce qu'il a tardé
Dieu ?
pas du tout
dans la plénitude
des temps
lorsque l'humanité
était suffisamment
maturée
lorsque l'humanité
a beau essayer
d'autres moyens
lorsque l'humanité
était convaincue
que d'elle-même
elle ne pourrait
jamais produire
les biens
les seigneurs
Jésus-Christ
arrivent
dans la plénitude
des temps
née d'une femme
née sous la loi
les seigneurs
arrivent
et la vie du Christ
ses silences
entre 12 ans
et 30 ans
les temps
de préparation
charpentier
habitude
normalité des vies
routine
vie dure
s'habituant
aux clous
au bois
on pense à Joseph
on pense à David
on pense à Moïse
David
15 ans
en attendant
depuis l'onction
jusqu'au moment
où il a été couronné
qu'est-ce qu'il a vécu
pendant ces temps
souffrance
diffamation
persécution
et quelle était
la résolution
de son coeur
comme on a vu
le 26 à l'ouverture
je marche
dans ta fidélité
je l'ave
mes mains
dans l'innocence
je ne vacille pas
je ne chancelle pas
je suis déterminé
à cultiver les biens
à faire les biens
et même lorsqu'il a eu
la chance
de tuer
son persécuteur
en juste
il a épargné sa vie
car c'était
une affaire
à Dieu dérégler
donc le kairos
des dieux
il est parfait
mais il a
cette condition
intéressante
si nous ne les relâchons
pas
là
quelqu'un a déjà dit
il faut qu'on fasse
attention
pour être sûr
qu'on n'a pas
désisté
de s'aimer
les chiens
à la moitié
c'est une condition
bien sûr
qui va
rendre évidente
l'authenticité
du salut
de cette personne
car un vrai
chrétien
la marque finale
de son assurance
de salut
c'est sa persévérance
la persévérance
des sangs
des fois
il peut
osciller
il peut être égaré
pendant le temps
dans sa vie
mais il reviendra
il progressera
il surmontera
ses péchés
mais nous ne pouvons
qu'être sûr
qu'il est proche
de recevoir
sa bénédiction
s'il ne relâche pas
donc c'est
la proximité
aussi
avec les résultats
qu'on espère
raconter
qu'on est
proche
des raccoltés
et c'est clair
que ça fait
la division
aussi
car ceux
qui vont
abandonner
définitivement
c'était
des imposteurs
ceux qui n'ont
pas eu
la capacité
de les tenir
tout simplement
car ils n'avaient
pas l'esprit
des dieux
donc car dieu
n'est pas
passif
des moqueries
nous pouvons
résister
ou persister
plutôt
à faire les biens
et résister
les difficultés
avec cette assurance
qu'il est
temps
des dieux
et parfait
et pendant
l'attente
nous ne sommes
pas privés
de la bénédiction
principale
qui est la présence
des dieux
et faire
recours à dieux
et pour conclure
nous avons
ces versets
qui nous dit
ainsi donc
pendant que nous
en avons l'occasion
pratiquons les biens
envers tous
et surtout envers
les frères
en la foi
donc ici
à nouveau
nous avons
la mention
des kairos
nous devons
persévérer
déterminer
à cultiver
les biens
car
les opportunités
pour les faire
sont précieuses
sont uniques
tant que nous avons
l'occasion
qu'est-ce que cela veut dire
on ne se moque pas
des dieux
pourquoi
car comment
on peut se moquer
de celui
qui est responsable
pour notre bâtiment
cardiaque
maintenant
qui peut faire
arrêter notre coeur
qui nous donne
les mouvements
l'être
et la respiration
et donc ici
c'est intéressant
tant qu'on respire
tant que nous
notre coeur
soit en train
de battre
nous devons
faire les biens
on n'a pas
d'excuse
peu importe
la croix
qu'on a porté
c'est une opportunité
précieuse
car c'est une opportunité
avant tout
exclusive
aux chrétiens
faire les biens
les biens selon
les termes des dieux
les biens qui sauvent
les biens qui scientifient
les biens qui sont faits
pour la gloire des dieux
ce n'est même pas
une générosité
intéressée avec la réputation
d'être vu
comme quelqu'un généreux
et nous n'avons
qu'est l'opportunité
de faire les biens
dans un monde
déchu
quand on arrivera
à la gloire
tout sera restauré
et tout ce qui concerne
l'essor
ou la destination éternelle
de la vie
de tous les êtres humains
sera déjà définie
pour toutes
donc la seule chose
qui importe
pour nous aujourd'hui
c'est d'être consacré
à cette opportunité
qui Dieu nous donne
précieuse
de faire les biens
à tous égards
mais surtout
les biens
du salut
et donc
Dieu nous donne
les privilèges
de coopérer
en intimité
avec ce qui est
son œuvre principale
encore dans cette
temporalité
quelle est l'œuvre
des dieux
sauver les personnes
et donc
cette opportunité
c'est Kairos
il a deux perspectives
d'une part
c'est la gouvernance
parfaite des dieux
l'état imparfait
pour intervenir
et pour apporter
la moisson
mais de l'autre côté
c'est l'état
de l'opportunité
pour nous
c'est un dévoire
c'est une exhortation
arrêtez de vous moquer
des dieux
saisissez l'opportunité
qu'il vous donne
aujourd'hui
car votre vie
a pour but
faire avancer
son règne
les biens
qu'on doit faire
c'est un bien
avant tout
qu'on doit faire
à nous-mêmes
pour ceux
qui concernent
les saluts
pour ceux
qui ne sont pas
sauvés à nouveau
les biens
c'est
seigneur
je me moquais
de toi
jusqu'ici
j'ai compris
ton évangile
je veux
véritablement
me réconcilier
avec toi
c'est de plaider
avec dieux
et c'est intéressant
la Bible
est très sévère
par rapport
à ceux
qui ont les plus
moqués de dieux
ceux qui étaient
exposés
quelque part
à la grâce
de dieux
à l'évangile
qu'elle ne donne pas
elle ne met pas
l'emphase
tant dans l'assurance
de la grâce
de dieux
qui pourrait être
conçue aux imposteurs
les langages
envers les imposteurs
sont très durs
dans la Bible
et peut-être
car
les niveaux
de leur répentance
doivent être affichés
de manière
suffisamment convaincante
peut-être
que dieux
aura de la pitié
peut-être
que dieux
vous pardonnera
vous rappelez
Simon les magiciens
s'il vous plaît
apôtre
priez pour moi
pour que dieux
me pardonne
prie toi même
vous comprenez
il y a quelque chose
que nous ne pouvons pas
faire pour les personnes
c'est elles
dans leur chambre
serrées
avec dieux
plaider
supplier
pour la répentance
authentique
pour les saluts
donc
salut pour ceux qui se sont
moqués de dieux
sans Christ
et pour nous
arrêtez de nous moquer
de dieux
en saisissant
toutes les ressources
des grâces
que dieux nous a données
pour progresser
en santé
mais c'est intéressant
le texte nous dit
faisons les biens
à tous
et là
clairement
à ceux qui supportent
PSG
et aux marseillais aussi
à ceux
des politiques
des mouches
ou des droites
aux homosexuels
et aux adultères
faire les biens
tous
et bien sûr
faire les biens
n'est pas
de négliger
les biens
qui doivent traverser
l'exhortation
la conviction
de péché
les chemins
qui mènent
à la répentance
car les biens
véritables
n'est pas
d'être en complice
avec leurs circonstances
les biens tous
pourquoi ?
car toute la race humaine
a été créée
à l'image des dieux
et toute la race humaine
a la valeur
du potentiel
pour vivre
une meilleure vie
sauf qu'ils sont tous
esclaves du péché
mais nous devons faire
les biens à tous
car c'est en faisant
les biens
qu'ils peuvent changer
les vies
et se réconcilier
avec Dieu
mais les textes
il avance
il dit
et surtout
envers les frères
en la foi
et ça c'est intéressant
pourquoi ?
donc d'abord
les biens
qu'on doit faire
envers les frères
en la foi
peuvent concerner
tout les sort
des biens
malheureusement
parfois
on va mal comprendre
cette réalité
car je vous donne
un exemple
à un moment donné
on a eu des événements
qui étaient pour des personnes
des business
à l'église
et quelque part
l'impression qu'on a eu
c'est que l'église
était plutôt vue
comme un réseau
pour une interaction
entre business
au-dedans
de la communauté
et ça développait
au sein de l'église
une attente
qu'on ait
aucune
ou aucun contact
si on a l'opportunité
de faire un travail
avec les membres
de l'église
qu'on fasse
qu'est ça ?
une relation utilitaire
et des fois
ça peut provoquer
un problème
car des fois
quelques personnes
ne sont pas en train
de faire leur travail
avec diligence
avec excellence
comme il faut
et donc
dans un certain sens
c'est bien
qu'on s'entraide
au sein de la foi
et qu'on fasse
les biens aussi
pour nous encourager
émotionnellement
à faire les meilleurs
travail qu'on puisse faire
pour la gloire des dieux
mais c'est clair
qu'il y a les biens
dont les textes
nous parlent ici
c'est un bien
infiniment
plus spirituel
que ça
sans négliger
une chose
il n'est pas oublié
que la priorité
du bien qu'on fait
à l'église
c'est la prospérité
spirituelle
et pourquoi
on doit avoir
cette solidarité
envers les chrétiens
déjà
car nous avons
et nous sommes exposés
aux difficultés
communes
dans ces mondes
qui les non-chrétiens
n'ont pas
des fardeaux exclusifs
pour nous les chrétiens
que j'ai déjà mentionné
l'église
elle est marquée
par la vulnérabilité
et nous sommes exposés
à la persécution
à l'extérieur
aux imposteurs
à l'intérieur
et donc
pour plus qu'on soit
dans un environnement
qui ont des vrais
atteints plutôt
d'être sécurisés
il faut qu'on soit sûr
surtout
quand on entend parler
de certains scandales
comme notre année
dernière a été marquée
par ça
à l'église
mondiale
on doit être vigilant
!
et on doit savoir
nous protéger
mutuellement
par cette vigilance
pour que nos frères
authentiques
et nos sœurs
ne soient pas
vulnérables
à l'exploit
des prédateurs
les galates
étaient exposés
et vulnérables
aux judaïsins
ça a failli
exploser complètement
cette église
et Paul
est en train
de restaurer
cette sensibilité
faisiez d'abord
les biens
envers ceux
qui vous êtes
plutôt sûrs
qui sont
affirmés
dans la foi
ceux qui
Dieu a établi
entre vous
soyez attentifs
soyez généreux
et c'est dans
ce sens là aussi
que j'évoquais
la situation
de cet homme
que
insiste
à donner
des opportunités
et des occasions
à des personnes
pour s'approcher
pour se développer
dans le ministère
malgré la fatigue
des déceptions
faire les biens
d'abord
à la famille
de la foi
c'est une question
de cohérence
maison de la foi
ici c'est
vraiment foyer
c'est
oikos
cette connotation
domestique
et la question
qu'on doit se poser
est-ce qu'on peut dire
comme David
que nous avons
les plaisirs
dans l'assemblée
des sangs
est-ce que je peux
regarder les visages
qui sont autour de moi
en ce moment
de cette église
et me dire
je vis avec ces personnes
une relation
de proximité
je la vois
comme ma famille
plus proche
que ma famille
biologique
qui n'est pas convertie
les foyers
de la foi
c'est important
car
selon Christ lui-même
l'amour
au-dedans
d'une église
est la preuve
sociologique
de la réalité
de l'évangile
entre nous
faire les biens
et voilà pourquoi
ceux entre nous
qui sont en train
constamment
de se moquer
de Dieu
de profiter
par exemple
qui est d'un côté
dans une relation
au sein de l'église
certains sont là
en train de dire
je porte le fardeau
je me sacrifie
je ferai ce que Dieu
attendait moi
mais de l'autre côté
l'autre en train de dire
je vais profiter
saisir
de sa prédisposition
de sa noblesse
pour mon
bel plaisir
pour ne pas changer
pour exploiter
cette relation
et là nous
nous devons faire
les biens
à tous
mais avant tout
à la famille
de la foi
surtout car
ce sont
ceux qui sont
un Christ
par la foi
c'est cette appartenance
mutuelle
dans son corps
mais c'est surtout
à cause du fait
qu'ils sont chers
pour Dieu
cette exhortation
elle est surtout
enracinée
et c'est ça
qui devrait nous emparer
les craintes
au sein de l'église
la Bible
elle appelle
tous les chrétiens
comme la prunelle
de ses yeux
les yeux des dieux
c'est l'épouse du Christ
c'est ses ailes
c'est cet amour
c'est cette jalousie
qui Dieu a
envers les siens
qui rend impossible
qu'un Dieu
qui ne peut pas être moqué
tolère
pendant longtemps
l'abus
des chrétiens
véritable
au sein d'une église
on ne se moque pas
de Dieu
plus tôt
plus tard
Dieu va intervenir
pour protéger
son église
et donc nous
on doit être
diligent
de les faire
constamment
car pour Dieu
ils sont chers
c'est pour eux
qu'Christ a donné
sa vie
c'est avec eux
qu'on va vivre
pendant toute l'éternité
et donc
tant qu'on respire
faisons les biens
à tous
mais surtout
à ceux
de la famille
de la foi
dans les caïros
des dieux
nous savons
que nous avons
de la consolation
pendant l'attente
pendant la persévérance
et dans les caïros
des dieux
nous sommes appelés
à s'aimer
les biens
à anticiper
les bénédictions
et la moisson
car Dieu
n'est pas mocap
je peux me dire
voici la croix
qui m'est réservée
je vais persévérer
à faire les biens
importants
cette croix
et Dieu
est en même temps
en train de dire
à ceux
qui sont en train
de se moquer
entre nous
cette opportunité
a une limite
plus tôt
ou plus tard
l'amant de Dieu
va péser
va s'alourdir
et Dieu
va opérer
le nettoyage
de son église
et Dieu